on nous a demandé de de que le les
ouvrages olympiques incarnent une
ambition française et singulièrement
dans le domaine environnemental et
incarne le meilleur des savoir-faes
Français le village olympique
aujourd'hui réduit de 47 % son bilan
carbone par rapport à ce qui se faisait
en 2019 le villagempique c'est plus de
300000 m² de surface de planché et ça on
le fait sans subvention publique cet
objectif de - 47 % c'est ce que la
stratégie nationale bacarbone euh fixe
comme objectif pour le l'industrie la
construction pour l'horizon 2030 2035 et
donc on l'atteint aujourd'hui sans
subvention publi si on peut l'atteindre
aujourd'hui sans subvention publique et
dans ce candri extrêmement court dans
lequel on est on peut le faire dans
toutes les préfectures de France
aujourd'hui le principal héritage
immatériel pour la filière de la
construction aujourd'hui il est là ça
veut dire que oui on peut décarboner la
construction on en est la
preuve on a travaillé sur l'économie
circulaire et singulièrement on on a a
développé un bâtiment qui met en place
un d'innovation de rupture et qui permet
de recycler l'intégralité de ces eaux
grises et noires ce qui permet une
économie d'eau potable de près de 60 %.
donc au moment où on parle de de
contrainte à la
sécheresse aujourd'hui on on a des
démonstrateurs qui ouvrent la voie pour
faire des économies extrêmement
substantielles en terme en terme d'eau
potable et puis on a pris en main la
question la résilience par rapport au
changement climatique et on a de on a
vérifié que nos bâtiments seraient
confortables à l'été 2050 c'est-à-dire
sous la canicule de 2003 et là-dessus
sans climatisation on atteint un taux de
confort sur dans 97 % des pièces du
village olympique là encore sans
climatisation ça a été à la fois
modélisé par Météo France et par dasso
système